und jetzt gerade ganz frische
informationen seitens der europäischen
union eu hat angekündigt untersuchungen
von den gräueltaten in den kiefer
vororten unterstützen zu wollen über
diese unerträglichen bilder hat der
ukrainische verteidigungsminister alexej
sitjow eben gerade gegenüber bild dass
hier gesagt
um es kurz zu machen es war ein echtes
militärisches kriegsverbrechen wir
warten auf neue nürnberger prozesse ich
denke die deutschen kennen die
nürnberger prozesse bestens die nächsten
nürnberger prozesse sind gegen die
russischen faschistischen fest
und auch vitali klitschko der
bürgermeister der stadt kiew hat
exklusiv mit paul ronzheimer gesprochene
unter das gesagt
das was in butter und anderen vororten
von kiew passiert ist kann man nur als
völkermord bezeichnen sagt vitali
klitschko es sind grausame
kriegsverbrechen die putin dort zu
verantworten hat sie will es nie mit
verbundenen händen erschossen wurden für
die ganze welt und insbesondere
deutschland kann es nur eine konsequenz
geben kein cent mehr darf nach russland
gehen das ist blutiges geld mit dem
menschen abgeschlachtet werden das gas
und öl embargo muss sofort kommen ja und
die wenigen bewohner von butscher die
brauchen dringend hilfsgüter essen
trinken medikamente
die von den eltern
die bringen ab und zu das nötigste was
man dort braucht aber schauen sie dort
in die gesichter der menschen von roger
schauen sie in ihre augen sieht man an
dass sie einen grauen erlebt haben das
jenseits der menschlichen
vorstellungskraft liegt
das dunkle gesicht eines
menschenverachtenden krieges in butter
einem vorort von kiew hinterlässt der
aggressor tod und zerstörung
die russischen besatzer wurden
herausgeschmissen sie laufen in richtung
weißrussland natürlich hinterlassen sie
viele leichen viele zerstörte häuser
viele gesprengte stellen
pure verzweiflung in den gesichtern das
leid wächst leichen auf den strassen
lebensmittel sind knapp doch wenigstens
kommen hilfsgüter an
jeder hat eine art müsli wasser wurde
aus dem reservoir geholt dann haben sie
uns auch etwas brot geschickt wir haben
es nicht gesehen es gestern haben sie
uns brot gegeben und so gab es nur bei
33 und das war alles
in der einstigen kornkammer europas
leiden die menschen hunger der tod
wartet an jeder ecke mitten in europa am
abgrund zur hölle
inklusion heute morgen nur deshalb in
der strategisch wichtigen küstenstadt
wurde eine ölraffinerie beschossen
mehrerer explosionen ist dort zu hören
gewesen sehen sie hier den rauch über
einem industriegebiet in eben gerade hat
russland diese angriffe auch bestätigt
von schiffen und flugzeugen aus seinen
raketen auf eine ölraffinerie und auf
drei treibstoff lager abgefeuert worden
das teilte das verteidigungsministerium
in moskau mit und wir schauen in die
hauptstadt nach kiew kriegs hauptstadt
ukrainische soldaten dort auf den
panzern sie patroullieren sie machen
sich ein bild über ihre stadt denn die
iranischen truppen haben nach angaben
der ukrainischen vize
verteidigungsminister in hanoi das
gesamte gebiet der region kiew wieder
unter ihre kontrolle gebracht wir fassen
für sie jetzt einmal zusammen dass in
diesen 36 kriegstag wichtig ist wie
gesagt regionen kiew ist wieder unter
ukrainischer kontrolle und auch wichtig
hunderten gelingt die flucht aus den
umkämpften städten fast 800 zivilisten
konnten mit eigenen fahrzeugen mario
pohl dieser eingekesselte stadt die seit
wochen ohne strom und wasser ist
verlassen und fast 500 konnten aus
berlin zu fliehen das treffen zwischen
putin und zielinski ist weiterhin nicht
möglich die friedensverhandlungen
zwischen der ukraine und russland haben
aus russischer sicht noch kein stand
erreichte ein direktes treffen mit den
beiden präsidenten
ermöglichen würde das heißt es von
russischer seite die baltischen staaten
haben das geschafft worüber wir hier die
ganze zeit diskutieren sie stellen die
gasimporte aus russland ein seit dem
ersten april fließt kein russisches
erdgas mehr nach lettland estland und
litauen und der litauische präsident
getan dass weder der rief die restlichen
eu-staaten auf twitter auf diesem
beispiel zu folgen sagt wenn wir es
können dann kann es der rest europas
auch und der ukrainische botschafter der
kreis bundespräsident steinmeier scharf
an andrej melik sagt für steinmeier war
und bleibt das verhältnis zu russland
etwas fundamentales jahr heiliges egal
was geschieht auch der angriffskrieg
spielt da keine große rolle mehr dass
das er dem tagesspiegel jetzt aber jetzt
schauen wir auf den held eines ganzen
landes vom komiker zum präsidenten zum
hoffnungs gebenden gesicht des krieges
so krems präsident wladimir selensky
unsere partei ödp ihr dorf ist zur gänze
wurzeln gereist denn die stadt wie wir
ich dorthin wo er aufgewachsen ist
[Musik]
ich bin hier im luftschutzkeller eines
hauses in krems eine stadt in der
ukraine südlich von kiew und das ist
nicht nur irgendeine stadt sondern das
ist auch die heimatstadt des
ukrainischen präsidenten wladimir lenski
und zwar wenn ich in dem haus in dem er
geboren und aufgewachsen ist wo er zur
schule gegangen ist ich bin mit meinen
kollegen her gekommen um mit den
menschen zu sprechen die ihnen wird
früher kennen und kaum waren wir da
gleich begann auch schon der luftalarm
die meisten menschen bleiben in ihren
wohnungen weil sie es nicht schaffen so
schnell runter zu kommen das ist ein
riesiges gebäude ein riesiges gebäuden
riesiger gebäudekomplex einzelne
menschen sind hier untergekommen tja und
jetzt warten wir bis der luftalarm
vorbei ist gestern haben die russen zum
ersten mal wirklich die stadt selbst
beschossen also die heimatstadt von
lenski wollen sie eigentlich angekündigt
hatten sich auf den dollars zu
konzentrieren die stimmung in der stadt
ist sehr nervös und viele befürchten
natürlich auch dass die russen genau
hier zuschlagen könnten nicht weil
dieses gebäude irgendein militärischen
wert hat sondern um einfach nur zu
zeigen zielinski wir zerstören auch
deine heimatstadt auch das haus in dem
du aufgewachsen ist
rhodia ist wie ein normaler junge
aufgewachsen wie alle unsere jungs im
hof
ist herumgerannt herumgesprungen zur
schule gegangen und als er zu dieser
comedy sendung gegangen ist war das für
uns ein zu großer stolz dass jemand von
hier mit dem wir zusammen gewohnt haben
so ein star geworden ist wir waren sehr
stolz
und als er zum präsidenten geworden ist
waren wir so richtig stolz wir haben so
eine hoffnung in ihn wohl hier ist
einfach das wurde nicht über ihn gesagt
ein clown ein schauspieler nein das ist
in erster linie ein mensch und jetzt
seit der krieg begonnen hat sind wir von
ihm komplett beeindruckt
wir stehen hinter ihm mit allem was wir
haben wir glauben
schaut nur wie in der letzten zeit
gealtert ist sehr stark das sind die
nerven die schlaflosigkeit
so witzig wir auf der bühne ist so ist
er auch im echten leben sein vater ist
auch so ganz humorvoll es sind gute
menschen
der vater war sehr gesprächig er hat
sich nie versteckt wenn die männer sich
draußen getroffen haben ist er auch dazu
gekommen er hat sich mit ihm unterhalten
domino gespielt die mutter saß auf der
bank der vater mit den männern gibt
der russische präsident sagt dass sie
von nazis und unabhängigen regiert
werden das ist schwachsinn weil er ja
war nie ein nazi oder drogenabhängiger
wie denn das
model bis dato zu wir haben kein
narzissmus alle menschen sind gleich
lang gäste krieg noch nicht bei uns
hoffentlich kommt er nicht zu uns obwohl
er näher kommt
wie kann man das machen sie klauen
morden vergewaltigen diese unmenschen
die wollte sie töten babys kinder in
mario pohl haben sie vor drei tagen ein
zwölfjähriges mädchen entführt wo
heimatdorf angekommen